oh boy am i freakin excited today we've
got the DJI goggles and I saw these a
while back when they did the launch of
thematic and I never got a chance to try
them at the launch event but today we've
got them here let's open it up I'm so
excited about this so after we do the
unboxing we're gonna go to this place
called sunken C which is exactly what it
sounds like it's a city if it's sunk off
the cliff this is what we came for the
problem is I don't like things that are
jarate so I don't like touching
cardboard
oh ho baby here it is if you have a
familiar with VR headsets I definitely
want to do a comparison of this between
meet well actually I have right here
ironically this is the Google daydream
so it already looks like it's a little
bit bigger than the daydream I'd love to
do a comparison to the PlayStation VR
I'll give you guys a sense of own size
of this thing
here they are it's a little heavy so
it's going to be interesting to see what
this feels like when I put it on what
else do we have in here this is very
dangerous for animals to make sure if
you guys ever have it if you keep them
away wow this feels like the hololens
demo that I did eat three like two years
ago our little converter here for other
places that are not the US okay
directions it's really jammed in this
I was a little cleansing wah all broken
and we've got a little plastic thing
here which looks like you to keep your
cord I'll cord it up this is a nice
little micro USB yes
I'm assuming is what you'll plug in to
your phantom 4 HDMI you can also use
this as a viewing experience of micro
HDMI and then an HDMI input which would
allow us to basically view any type of
content from some sort of HDMI source so
looks like I'm gonna actually need my
computer to activate it and it takes
about 4 hours to do a complete charge
this does not work here in the US and I
don't have a converter I'm going to use
my avatar jury just has little USB ports
out there okay that's in this is going
to be the first time in putting this on
so what do I look like here I look cool
it look like somebody who you see on the
screen be like I want to be her friend
don't answer that I'm going to adjust
whoa it's so the screen actually looks
really good oh my goodness so right here
on the action has set itself we have a
micro SD card slot to a place for
headphones and this is the HDMI in the
micro HDMI so this looks like it's just
the release so that you can release that
from the headband this is how you turn
it on such a little on button and here's
some on-screen controls that allow you
to control what's actually happening
inside of the headset but then you have
to this is the sync then that whole yeah
it's like on the road and when you need
to sing
like the thumb controller on the runnin
and then this little thing will probably
blink green I mean it's like a Wi-Fi or
like a Bluetooth thing mmm
what he said up that's Nathan you'll say
hi to them hmm
right now we're charging here's the
micro USB charge slot so those little
wheel just will let you adjust the size
of the headband submit it to your dome
piece let's do a quick little size
comparison of the DJI goggles with the
playstation alarm the goggles are bigger
than the sony as you can see here so the
technology and this is a little bit less
than these two guys but this is Google's
a dream you can just put one of your
pixel phones right into here and you're
able to basically have a VR headset
right from your phone which I use these
a bunch and they're really cool in their
super light because the material is are
made oh it's cloth it's super soft it
feels like t-shirt and we let us charge
and then we're going to activate it it
says here that you can actually activate
it with the DJI go for app or you can
use the DJI assistant app to which you
need your computer for so after that
happens then it's time to fly those two
cool modes that you can use using the
goggles the first one we're going to try
out right now and head tracking feature
so basically as I move my head that will
be controlling the camera and the gimbal
as I use the controller I can look
around and use the camera with my head
which is pretty crazy to really think
about so we give you guys a quick demo
right here on the ground very how's this
that's good look look to your left and
to your right and now nod your head back
and forth to left and right
and yeah I don't quit so far cuz I'm
backing it out so kind of like in the
middle that's so cool so this is really
the best example that we can show you
guys I'm moving my head and the camera
is also moving with it look look at this
this is awesome the squirrel came right
up to you really
this is so insane I can see myself
this is inception
[Music]
I'm uh I'm see I can see you filming me
but like it's like an hour body
experience I'm freaking out
holy crap oh we will refill it odds this
is so freaking crazy and absolutely
losing my freakin mind right now
[Music]
this is actually my first time flying
with any type of headset or any kind of
s can do golly ever and it's kind of
unreal
[Music]
like I can't believe it I'm looking like
she later
[Music]
our fast movements are definitely not
recommended I'm not sure if I footage
it'll look like as I'm not quite used to
flying like this we're coming back
because it says super strong magic
[Music]
oh my good well this view is hideous
turn it around ah beautiful so if I walk
back
it changes the camera I'm so scared cuz
I can't do anything like wow I wish
everyone else is here
oh cool all right so what are you trying
out now so this is what the the head
tracking movements the basically the
goggle dictate the direction of the
aircraft so if you look at the
controller I'm only going forward I'm
not turning left or right but then as I
turn my head left you can catch the
video and recording right now to see so
the term I had left the aircraft turns
and I don't have to turn all the way
around I just turn my head left and then
when I want to stop a turn I face the
front again and then it keeps going so
the whole time I'm just pressing forward
on the aircraft but then I use my head
to go in the direction I want to go so
when I go left a little bit more and
then stop turn my head back forward
again to stop and then I want to turn
right so go right turning right and stop
and laughs and if you look up I'll be
directly over us here I'm out over the
street there's us down there I don't
know if you can see me oh yeah we also
see ya there you are so I'm just I'm
literally steering the drum of my head
that's so great
so here what I'll do is I'll kind of
close
yeah it's like flying a weird VR game
loofa like a safe enough slide
what do you think I mean it's so
different from flying any of the other
drones the Phantom the inspire it makes
me want to get a Mavic that's kind of
how I feel about it it's pretty cool
it's pretty amazing it's just a
different experience all right guys
that's it for the DDI goggles either
super cool I had so much fun flying with
them but yeah let me know what you guys
think let me know if you've ever flown
fpv with drones before it's very cool
definitely something I would have to get
used to and practice more but I'm
definitely going to be doing more of
that in the future I'll see you guys
later
[Music]